hey 42 here in 1904 the World's Fair was
held in st. Louis Missouri to celebrate
the Louisiana Purchase 100 years earlier
when the United States purchased the
enormous territory of Louisiana from
France for a pitiful sum of fifteen
million dollars part of the celebrations
was to holding at the 1904 Summer
Olympics this was the first time the
still young United States had hosted the
Olympics and so it should have been the
grandest sporting event of the century
after all affair itself was magnificent
but in actuality the 1904 Olympics was
two strangest Olympics in history and
tells a story of poison medical
malfeasance and cheating so unbelievable
you couldn't make it up but before I
reveal what really happens that year do
you want to know what I've always wanted
to do become a law of my very own
medieval castle and that's exactly what
I've been having gloated fun during
recently playing hustle castle you have
kindly sponsored today's video in
hostile Castle you can build your very
own castle and expand it exactly how you
want to once you train peasants to
become fearsome warriors you can do that
want to send out your fighters to battle
orcs giant skeletons and Dragons you can
do that too I've been having so much fun
training up my castle dwellers to become
powerful fighters it's always exciting
when you open a mythical chest because
you can get epic purple weapons and
sometimes if you're really lucky
legendary orange weapons I just got this
awesome legendary axe which I used to
absolutely destroy this boss my tip to
you is to always leave one of your
dwellers in the training room to level
up whilst you send your other fighters
out to battle what I love most about
hustle castle it's the engaging
storyline the characters are so funny
and the animations have this really
unique cartoon style which I just think
looks absolutely brilliant oh and the
music is just so addictive it really
draws you in and makes you feel like a
badass medieval Lord you can find my
clan in-game under the name 40 - be sure
to hop into game join my clan today and
slay some orcs
download hustle castle via mine link
below enter your nickname and get a
special bonus for new players 250
diamonds and 3500 gold pieces I know you
won't regret it and I'll see you in game
right from the start it wasn't looking
good because of recent russo-japanese
war tensions and difficulty getting to
st. Louis which involved a 1,000 mile
train journey the vast majority of the
foreign contestants who were invited to
compete failed to show up one of the
headline event was the marathon but it
turned out to be one of the most
scandalous events in the history of
sports let's set the ugly scene by
taking a quick look at some of the
marathon contestants there were only 32
runners in total from four nations most
were former Boston Marathon winners or
hopefuls but there were also some truly
bizarre characters that turned up that
year in st. Louis such as Fred lorz a
bricklayer from New York who did all of
his training in the dead of night
because of his profession he wore a paid
trip to compete in the Olympic marathon
as a prize for placing first in a local
amateur 5-mile race then there were 10
Greek contestants who had never run a
marathon in their lives plus two members
of the South African to Swarna tribe who
showed up in bare feet and my personal
favorite contestant was an absolute nut
job from Cuba Felix kabaah ha also known
as under in kabah ha Felix was a mailman
who dreamed of competing at the Olympic
marathon so during his postal rounds he
would raise money for his trip to
America asking people to sponsor him
remarkably he was successful and sure
enough in 1904 his bags were packed and
he was on his way to st. Louis but what
did he do with all that sponsorship
money well he made it as far as New
Orleans and spent it all on drinking and
gambling yes every penny he was forced
to make the rest of his journey by
hitchhiking country key
across the wilderness at least it was
good practice for him this legend
arrived at the starting post of the race
dressed in a bar a long-sleeve shirt
full-length dress trousers and heavy
hiking boots completely opposite to the
rest of the contestants who were
sporting much lighter clothing and
footwear Felix took the smart decision
to hastily cut the bottom half of his
trousers off to fashion them into shorts
before the race began the course was
24.8 5 miles the roads if you can call
him that snaked up and down punishingly
steep inclines and declines across a
total of seven hills at one point the
route passed directly through the center
of town across a busy road where runners
had to dodge speeding two-way traffic
and a horde of pedestrians most of the
ground along the route was absolutely
thick with dust and loose Jacky stones
that cut into the runners feet this dust
would soon be the undoing of one
particular contestant to add insult to
injury it was a brutally hot August day
and temperatures soared up to 33 degrees
Celsius at Frio 3 p.m. the starting
pistol fired and they were off
immediately the runners kicked up dried
dirt and dust into the air choking the
lungs of everyone even the spectators to
make matters even worse these were the
very early days of automobiles and the
event organisers had fought it a wise
idea to ask to support vehicles to drive
a few meters in front of the runners
throughout the race the car wheels of
course kicked up a tremendous cloud of
dust that the runners had no choice but
to run directly into and breathe in this
officiating cloud caused major issues
all the runners were struggling and had
all slowed down way below their usual
pace the event organisers had only
placed one water stop along the course a
water tower at the six mile mark so they
had very little opportunity to ease
their suffering as he will soon learn
there was a sudden inconsiderate reason
the organisers only provide
water stopped not logged into the race
the combination of dehydration and dust
clouds almost caused the first ever
modern Olympic marathon death after 19
miles
William Garcia of California collapsed
at the side of the road and began
coughing up copious quantities of blood
he would have died right there and then
if not for a passing bystander who
picked him up and took him to the
hospital where it was discovered that
the fine road dust had flooded into his
lungs and coated his esophagus in a
thick layer it had also destroyed his
stomach lining and was eating away at
his insides like sandpaper
he had a near fatal internal hemorrhage
the dust caused another contender John
Lordan to start vomiting and so he gave
up and went home how were the South
African runners getting on you may be
wondering not a lot better one of them
Len tau had been chased miles off course
by her pack of wild dogs which is not
typically something you see today on
televised Olympic marathons what about
my spiritual hero of this story
Felix Cavanaugh how is he faring well
I'm pleased to say pretty well Fred Laws
the bricklayer was in the lead but Felix
was not far behind him in his cumbersome
dress clothes he repeatedly stopped at
the side of the road to chat to
spectators
when he reached a busy crosstown traffic
section of the race he flagged down a
passing car he had noticed they were
munching on peaches and Felix rava
fancying one himself asked if he could
have one but they refused so Felix
reached into the car grabs two peaches
and ran away
in fact Felix was far more concerned
with devouring fruit than actually
winning the race you know that's very
race he had begged and fundraised just
to be a part of because a little while
later having finished his peaches he ran
off the road into a nearby orchard and
ate a few apples he plucked from a tree
little did he know before it was too
late they were rotten inside and gave
him awful stomach cramps so he curled up
on the floor and slept them off this
allowed another
some Mela to overtake him and so he and
Fred lorz were now in second and first
place respectively
but then Mela was also attacked by about
two stomach cramps probably from the
dust not rotten apples so just gave up
on the race then at the nine mile marker
Fred loss still in the lead also
succumbed to stomach cramps and
exhaustion did he give up not quite he
jumped into one of the support vehicles
at the side of the road and caught a
lift for the next eleven miles after
which he got out of the car and ran the
remaining four point eight five miles
back to the finish line at the stadium
acting coy as though his automobile
based shortcut never happened he
confidently waved at the pensive crowds
and ripped through the unbroken tape of
the finish line to claim first place his
time was three hours 13 minutes wars
initially acted as though he hadn't
cheated but then a spectator came
forward just as the president's daughter
Alice Roosevelt who is lowering a wreath
and gold medal around his neck to the
adoration of cheering crowds the
spectator loudly uncovered his eleven
mile car journey and laws quickly
changed his tune he claimed he had only
done it as a joke and never intended to
actually claim the win sure the crowd
instantly become booing him in the
officials revoked his win so who was the
real winner of the 1904 Olympic marathon
well that would be Thomas Hicks an
English American brass worker for
Massachusetts at 10 miles in Hicks was
exhausted severely dehydrated and
begging for water he passed the only
water stop four miles ago but no matter
how much he pleaded with his two
handlers for a drink they point blankly
refused all they did was sponge out his
mouth with warm water the reason well
the events chief organiser James Edward
Sullivan one of the founders of the
Amateur Athletic Union was secretly
using the race as an experiment on the
effects of four
dehydration that's why he had only
allowed one war to stop at six miles and
chose a choking Li hot and dry summer
day for the run longer routes that he
knew was perilously dusty and strewn
with rocks the evil bastard had ideas
that purposeful dehydration would
somehow allow athletes to perform better
of course we now know it to be quite the
opposite and dehydration can all too
easily be fatal so Hicks was being
refused water and had a warm damp sponge
shoved into his mouth but it gets even
worse
his handlers then made him drink a
homemade mix of egg whites and
strychnine yes what you're thinking is
correct strychnine is a poison and a
deadly one of that it only takes a small
dose to kill a man you see at this time
the Olympics and most professional
sports events for that matter had no
anti-doping laws it wouldn't be until
1928 until the first such rules were
introduced and it was commonly believed
that in small doses strychnine was a
stimulant that enhanced athletes
performance strychnine works by
interfering with and stopping the nerve
signals that communicate with the
muscles in your body slowly the muscles
including the heart shuts down now it
may just be me but he isn't a poison
that shuts down muscles the very last
thing on the planet you would want to
give a runner only a few miles out from
the finish line of an Olympic marathon
sure enough the poisonous cocktail began
to ravage Hix body and shut it down he
had to be held up by his two handlers
which at this point in time was also not
forbidden in the Olympics they were
practically dragging him along with his
limp legs drooping in his feet trailing
behind him in the dust but hearing news
that laws had just been disqualified
from the race and with the first-place
still up for grabs
Hicks found a second wind his trainers
fought fantastic what a wonderful
opportunity to poison him yet again
that's right at this point they gave him
yet another deadly cocktail of
strychnine and
this time they allowed him a swig of
brandy to wash it down and they rinsed
off his body and head with warm water
with his muscles locking up and
beginning to spasm and his complexion as
pale as death
Hicks fought through the poison dust and
heat and over the last two miles of the
race his pace began to quicken
hallucinating he thought that the finish
line was yet another 20 miles away he
repeatedly begged his handlers for water
and arrest but they refused and
continued to push him along by the time
they reached the stadium his handlers
practically carried him across the
finish line nevertheless he was declared
the winner
not that Hicks knew about it he had
collapsed on the floor inches from death
but mercifully he was saved by four
doctors
and an hour later he had regained his
composure and consciousness Hicks would
overtime 3 hours and 28 minutes which is
the slowest Olympic marathon time in
history in fact the since lowest was a
whole half hour faster demonstrating how
to leap bizarre and punishing to all of
the contestants this 1904 event truly
was our good old Cuban friend Felix
kavaja had now woken up and despite
pissing about pinching peaches for
motorists and taking a nap he still
managed to come in fourth place though
his finishing time is unknown it's
thought that if he hadn't have taken
enough he probably would have won so the
winner of the United States first
Olympic marathon was a man who was
poisoned twice along the route and he
was only slightly ahead of a man who
cracked jokes with bystanders and took a
nap under a tree was an absolute
shambles the 1904 Olympic Maroof
turned out to be but my god I don't
think there will ever be another one
quite like it ever again thanks for
watching and thanks again to hustle
castle for sponsoring this video don't
forget to download the game using the
special link in the description